come and learn a BM and daddy while oh
my god alone and Allah Allah I'm not
honor the MFE be nurse it was another
eat ketchup odisha for said let me Nina
manana remain genie he wouldn't say Oh
Karl atala Poland colima TallyMan lipid
lena bena what if he Villanova tajima in
[Arabic recitation]
well Idina Hammond Sun Nevada he was
sending water sliema vamos ala sayyidina
muhammad in walla missing dinner Hamid
camel select ala Sayyidina Ibrahim o
Allah Lisa he denied Raheem in Nakatomi
domoj eid mubarak ala sayyidina
[Arabic recitation]
caliber ala Sayyidina Ibrahim o Allah
let me say eating I bro hymn figured I
meaning in the caja miedema jean-luc
Amir Agha wearing all a hurry Madonna
ominous luckily we have no passenger
this is Halloween Hamid fea in garage
Alicia fateh extremely Minnesota to what
the sleen re saiyan ocellata come
northern iowa sir walter hagen a Telugu
nollie please dear brothers move forward
may work in remote desert mafia in your
brother space johanna in harmony with a
pedo con la festa who fill my jealousy
festival yes haha ok all Muslims last
weekend i attended a conference for the
imams of north america with 167 other
emails from the united states and canada
it was an excellent
and very successful conference which
focused on many areas of concern to
message to messages and man's in North
America it also focused on solutions to
many of problems facing our communities
such as youth marriage politics and the
rule of political and religious part
parties in our masajid dear brothers and
sisters very important we know if you
respect a man this mean you respect
respect to prophet muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wasallam and also my advice for
you very important don't be for some
group or one group don't follow only
ones all surface or brotherhood or any
party because allah subhana allah tala
give us highest religion and allah
subhana allah says in the dinner and
allah islam be all of them because the
islam include
all of them dear Sophie B 1 B EE D good
listen this is very important don't
follow subgroup and put another party on
another group in there with all you
should know that allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala has a plane finna pull into
this Dale distinct groups and that the
amounts belonging to a distinguished
group because they are the inheritor in
the inheritors of the prophets peace and
blessings upon them oh the war team and
dear brothers and sisters come in deeper
and in many places that refer to their
elevated status and importance to allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala and his messenger
sallallahu ala he were he was happy he
was under a massive hardon what Allah
says and we made their leaders guide
guiding to our commands and inspire them
to do right your T's to perform player
and this distribute charity and they
wear our worshipers Omashu Hannah
Montana also says and we wanted to show
favor to those
who where Oh place a place on earth and
to make them examples and make them
there in heaters and insert and but
Allah Allah subhana what Allah says
which means and when applying was tried
by his Lord and fulfill fulfilled his
commands his Lord said I had made you a
leader or a leader for night mankind
applying us and will there be leaders
for my offspring and he's not said he
couldn't does not include evil doers I
was hollin what Allah says can you
compare the one who has certainty from
his Lord recited by a witness from from
him and before that the book of musa
alayhi salam as an example and I messy
and in another verse before this was the
book of uses an example and immersing
and this is a true book in the Arabic
language that one's thus who do learn
and it brings good news for their
lighters in surat furqan allah subhana
what allah says
which means and does that say o Lord
grant us from our spouses and children
that comfort of our eyes and makes us
guys to their BIOS the meaning of anon
in the Arabic language is the one who is
an example and who is a leader who guys
to work good and away from evil the
prophets were given this title because
the people shouldn't should learn to
follow them allah subhana allah says
allah subhana allah says on the prophets
which means and we let them examples to
guide to our commands the same is true
for those who follow and who were placed
in this position the image guide people
to follow their actions and judgments
this is no known as the known as the
lesser Imam the messenger sallallaahu ru
ru wasabi wasallam said the man is there
to be followed if he found the people
will pull bow if if he prostrates they
must prostrate
they must not differ with their Imam the
messenger sallallahu alayhi wasallam
also said the one who calls to prior is
entrusted but the e man is his guarantee
is a guarantee hola guide a man and
forgive their color to prior Allah make
us sincere in heritage and immense and
make us scores of action guided and
gutting and forgive us our parents and
all of the Muslims Allah muscle Islam
Owens mean whiny Kelly metal happy with
inna allaha Marcia d'alene allah masha
dilemma when I am / FM Rashad velocity
Minka rahamallah he mean hello Magellan
Allah leukopenia mama a llama a la
Mina's Regina was only 18 apple bottom
well Jalen early leukopenia mama a llama
fern and our Hannah what about a novice
al mana Wahine abhinav oh sorry hachi on
Elena a lot more freely jamaat al
halloween women a Shahada makan woman
army repeated lying and hiding wondering
where son Allah maken dinner I muslimeen
Fe polemic on a long
IM will have to hop concert nitida
wiring available till eternity nada al
amor finale I'm a bit autonomy well soon
[Arabic recitation]
alayhi wasallam wild iguana I mean hun
do lillahi rabbil aalameen in a lion
will be you were a son ye tae is in
aruba when i'm in faccia you will carry
one baby you know i will come running up
into the karoon welcome solitaire from